[Music]
here we look at the math behind an
animation like this one what's known as
a complex Fourier series each little
vector is rotating at some constant
integer frequency and when you add them
together tip to tail the final tip draws
out some shape over time by tweaking the
initial size and angle of each vector we
can make it drop pretty much anything
that we want and here you'll see how
before diving into it all I want you to
take a moment to just linger on how
striking this is this particular
animation has 300 rotating arrows in
total go full screen for this if you can
the intricacy is worth it think about
this the action of each individual arrow
is perhaps the simplest thing you could
imagine rotation at a steady rate and
yet the collection have all added
together is anything but simple and the
mind-boggling complexity is put into an
even sharper focus the farther we zoom
in revealing the contributions of the
littlest quickest and downright frenetic
arrows when you consider the chaotic
frenzy that you're looking at and the
clockwork rigidity underlying all the
motions it's bizarre how the swarm acts
with the kind of coordination to trace
out some very specific shape and unlike
much of the emergent complexity you find
elsewhere in nature this is something
that we have the math to describe and to
control completely just by tuning the
starting conditions nothing more we can
make this swarm conspire in all of the
right ways to draw anything that you
want provided that you have enough
little arrows what's even crazier is
that the ultimate formula for all of
this is incredibly short now often
Fourier series are described in terms of
something that looks a little different
functions of real numbers being broken
down as a sum of sine waves that turns
out to be a special case of this more
general rotating vector phenomenon that
will build up to but it's where Fourier
himself started and there's good reason
for us to start the story there as well
technically this is the third video in a
sequence of
the heat equation what Fourier was
working on when he developed his big
idea I would like to teach you about
Fourier series in a way that doesn't
depend on you coming from those chapters
but if you have at least a high-level
idea for the problem from physics which
originally motivated this piece of math
it gives some indication for just how
unexpectedly far-reaching Fourier series
are all you need to know is that we had
a certain equation which tells us how
the temperature distribution on a rod
would evolve over time and incidentally
it also describes many other phenomena
unrelated to heat and while it's hard to
directly use this equation to figure out
what will happen to an arbitrary heat
distribution there's a simple solution
if the initial function just happens to
look like a cosine wave with the
frequency tuned so that it's flat at
each end point specifically as you graph
what happens over time these waves
simply get scaled down exponentially
with higher frequency waves having a
faster exponential decay the heat
equation happens to be what's known in
the business as a linear equation
meaning if you know two solutions and
you add them up that sum is a new
solution you can even scale them each by
some constant which gives you some dials
to turn to construct a custom function
solving the equation
this is a fairly straightforward
property that you can verify for
yourself but it's incredibly important
it means that we can take our infinite
family of solutions these exponentially
decaying cosine waves scale a few of
them by some custom constants of our
choosing and combined them to get a
solution for a new tailor-made initial
condition which is some combination of
cosine waves one important thing I'd
like you to notice is that when you
combine these waves because the higher
frequency ones decay faster the sum that
you construct will tend to smooth out
over time as all the high frequency
terms quickly go to zero leaving only
the low frequency terms dominating so in
a funny way all of the complexity in the
evolution of this heat distribution
which the heat equation implies is
captured by this difference in the decay
rates for the different pure frequency
components it's at this point that
Fourier gains immortality I think most
normal people at this stage would say
well I can solve the heat equation when
the initial distribution just happens to
look like a wave or a sum of waves but
what a shame it is that most real-world
distributions don't at all look like
that I mean for example let's say you
brought together two rods which were
each at some uniform temperature and you
wanted to know what happens immediately
after they come into contact to make the
number simple let's say the temperature
of the left rod is one degree and the
right rod is negative one degree and at
the total length L of the combined two
rods is one what this means is our
initial temperature distribution is a
step function which is so obviously
different from a sine wave or the sum of
sine waves don't you think I mean it's
almost entirely flat not wavy and for
God's sake it's even discontinuous and
yet Fourier thought to ask a question
which seems absurd how do you express
this as a sum of sine waves even more
boldly how do you express any initial
distribution as a sum of sine waves and
it's more constrained than just that you
have to restrict yourself to adding
waves which satisfy a certain boundary
condition and as we saw last video that
means working with these cosine
functions whose frequencies are all some
whole number multiple of a given base
frequency and by the way if you were
working with some different boundary
condition say that the endpoints have to
say
you'd have a different set of waves at
your disposal to piece together in this
case simply replacing that cosine
expression with a sine it's strange how
often progress in math looks more like
asking a new question rather than simply
answering old ones Fourier really does
have a kind of immortality now with his
name essentially synonymous with the
idea of breaking down functions and
patterns as combinations of simple
oscillations it's really hard to
overstate just how important and
far-reaching that idea turned out to be
well beyond anything that Fourier
himself could have imagined and yet
the origin of all this is a piece of
physics which at first glance has
nothing to do with frequencies and
oscillations if nothing else this should
give you a hint about the general
applicability of Fourier series now hang
on I hear some of you saying none of
these sums of sine waves that you're
showing are actually the step function
there are all just approximations and
it's true any finite sum of sine waves
will never be perfectly flat except for
a constant function nor will it be
discontinuous but Fourier thought more
broadly considering infinite sums in the
case of our step function it turns out
to be equal to this infinite sum where
the coefficients are 1 negative 1/3 plus
1/5 minus 1/7 and so on for all the odd
frequencies and all of it is rescaled by
4 divided by pi i'll explain where those
numbers come from in a moment before
that it's worth being clear about what
we mean by a phrase like infinite sum
which runs the risk of being a little
bit vague consider the simpler context
of numbers where you could say for
example that this infinite sum of
fractions equals pi divided by 4 as you
keep adding the terms one by one at all
times what you have is rational it never
actually equals the irrational pi
divided by 4 but the sequence of partial
sums approaches PI over 4 which is to
say the numbers you see while never
equaling PI over 4 get arbitrarily close
to that value and they stay arbitrarily
close to that value
that's all a mouthful to say so instead
we abbreviate and just say the infinite
sum equals PI over four with functions
you're doing the same thing but with
many different values in parallel
consider a specific input and the value
of all of these scaled cosine functions
for that input if that input is less
than 0.5 as you add more and more terms
the sum will approach 1 if that input is
greater than 0.5 as you add more and
more terms it would approach negative 1
and at the input 0.5 itself all of the
cosines are 0 so the limit of the
partial sums is also 0 and that means
that somewhat awkwardly for this
infinite sum to be strictly true we do
have to prescribe the value of this set
function at the point of discontinuity
to be 0 sort of halfway along the jump
analogous to an infinite sum of rational
numbers being irrational the infinite
sum of wavy continuous functions can
equal honest-to-goodness
equal a discontinuous flat function
getting limits into the game allows for
qualitative changes which finite sums
alone never could there are multiple
technical nuances that I'm sweeping
under the rug here does the fact that
we're forced into a certain value for
the step function at the point of
discontinuity make any difference for
the heat flow problem for that matter
what does it really mean to solve a PDE
with a discontinuous initial condition
can we be sure that the limit of
solutions to the heat equation is also a
solution and can we be sure that all
functions actually have a Fourier series
like this if not when not these are
exactly the kind of questions which real
analysis is built to answer but it falls
a bit deeper in the weeds than I'd like
to go here so I'll relegate that all to
links in the video's description the
upshot is that when you take the heat
equation solutions associated with these
cosine waves and you add them all up all
infinitely many of them you do get an
exact solution describing how the step
function will evolve over time and if
you had done this in 1822 you would have
become immortal for doing so the key
challenge in all of this
of course is to find these coefficients
so far we've been thinking about
functions with real number outputs but
for the computations I'd like to show
you something more general than what
Fourier originally did applying to
functions whose output can be any
complex number in the 2d plane which is
where all these rotating vectors from
the opening come back into play why the
added complexity well aside from being
more general in my view the computations
become cleaner and it's easier to
understand why they actually work more
importantly it sets a good foundation
for the ideas that will come up later on
in the series like the Laplace transform
and the importance of exponential
functions
we'll still think of functions whose
input is some real number on a finite
interval say from 0 up to 1 for
simplicity but whereas something like a
temperature function will have outputs
on the real number line this broader
view will let the outputs wander
anywhere in the two-dimensional complex
plane you might think of such a function
as a drawing with a pencil tip tracing
out different points in the complex
plane as the input ranges from 0 to 1
and instead of sine waves being the
fundamental building block as you saw at
the start we'll focus on breaking these
functions down as a sum of little
vectors all rotating at some constant
integer frequency functions with real
number outputs are essentially really
boring drawings a one-dimensional pencil
sketch you might not be used to thinking
of them like this since usually we
visualize such a function with a graph
but right now the path being drawn is
only in the output space
if you do one of these decompositions
into rotating vectors for a boring 1
dimensional drawing what will happen is
that the vectors with frequency 1 and
negative 1 will have the same length and
there'll be horizontal reflections of
each other when you just look at the sum
of these two as they rotate that sum
stays fixed on the real number line and
it oscillates like a sine wave if you
haven't seen it before this might be a
really weird way to think about what a
sine wave is since we're used to looking
at its graph rather than the output
alone wandering on the real number line
but in the broader context of functions
with complex number outputs this
oscillation on the horizontal line is
what a sine wave looks like similarly
the pair of rotating vectors with
frequencies 2 and negative 2 will add
another sine wave component and so on
with the sine waves we were looking for
earlier now corresponding to pairs of
vectors rotating in opposite directions
so the context that Fourier originally
studied breaking down real valued
functions into sine waves is a special
case of the more general idea of 2d
drawings and rotating vectors
[Music]
and at this point maybe you don't trust
me that widening our view to complex
functions makes things easier to
understand but bear with me it really is
worth the added effort to see the fuller
picture and I think you'll be pleased
with how clean the actual computation is
in this broader context you may also
wonder why if we're gonna bump things up
into two dimensions we don't just talk
about 2d vectors what is the square root
of negative one have to do with anything
well the heart and soul the Fourier
series is the complex exponential e to
the I times T as the input T takes
forward with time this value walks
around the unit circle at a rate of one
unit per second in the next video you'll
see a quick intuition for why
exponentiating imaginary numbers walks
around circles like this from the
perspective of differential equations
and beyond that as the series progresses
I hope to give you some sense for why
complex Exponential's like this are
actually very important in theory you
could describe all of the Fourier series
stuff purely in terms of vectors and
never breathe a word of I the square
root of negative 1 the formulas will
become more convoluted but beyond that
leaving out the function e to the X
would somehow no longer authentically
reflect why this idea turns out to be so
useful for solving differential
equations for right now if you want you
can think of e to the I T just as a
notational shorthand for describing
rotating vectors but just keep in the
back of your mind that it is more
significant than mere shorthand you'll
notice I'm being a little loose with
language using the words vector and
complex numbers somewhat interchangeably
in large part because thinking of
complex numbers as little arrows makes
the idea of adding a lot of them
together easier to visualize all right
armed with the function e to the I times
T let's write down a formula for each of
these rotating vectors that we're
working with for right now think of each
of them has started pointing one unit to
the right at the number one the easiest
vector to describe is the constant one
which stays at the number one never
moving or if you prefer its
quote-unquote rotating just at a
frequency of zero
then there will be the vector rotating
one cycle every second which we write as
e to the 2 pi I times T that 2pi is
there because as T goes from 0 to 1
he needs to cover a distance of 2pi
along the circle technically in what's
being shown it's actually one cycle
every 10 seconds so that things aren't
too dizzying I'm slowing everything down
by a factor of 10 we also have a vector
rotating at 1 cycle per second in the
other direction e to the negative 2 pi I
times T similarly the one going to
rotations per second is e to the 2 times
2 pi I times T where that 2 times 2 pi
in the exponent describes how much
distance is covered in one second and we
go on like this over all integers both
positive and negative with a general
formula of e to the N times 2 pi times I
T notice this makes it more consistent
to write that constant vector as e to
the 0 times 2 pi times I T which feels
like an awfully complicated way to write
the number 1 but at least it fits the
pattern the control that we have the set
of knobs and dials we get to turn is the
initial size and direction of each of
these numbers the way we control that is
by multiplying each one by some complex
constant which I'll call C sub n for
example if we wanted the constant vector
not to be at the number 1 but to have a
length of 0.5 C 0 would be 0.5 if we
wanted the vector rotating at 1 cycle
per second to start off at an angle of
45 degrees we'd multiply it by a complex
number which has the effect of rotating
it by that much which you can write as e
to the PI fourths times I and if its
initial length needed to be 0.3 then the
coefficient C 1 would be 0.3 times that
amount
likewise everyone in our infinite family
of rotating vectors has some complex
constant being multiplied into it which
determines its initial angle and its
total magnitude our goal is to express
any arbitrary function f of T say this
one that draws an eighth-note
as T goes from 0 to 1 as a sum of terms
like this so we need some way of picking
out these constants 1 by
given the data of the function itself
the easiest of these to find is the
constant term this term represents a
sort of center of mass for the fall
drawing if you were to sample a bunch of
evenly spaced values for the input T as
it ranges from 0 to 1 the average of all
the outputs of the function for those
samples will be the constant term C 0 or
more accurately as you consider finer
and finer samples the average of the
outputs for these samples approaches C 0
in the limit what I'm describing finer
and finer sums of a function for samples
of T from the input range is an integral
an integral of f of T from 0 to 1
normally since I'm framing this all in
terms of averages you would divide the
integral by the length of the input
range but that length is 1 so in this
case taking an integral and taking an
average are the same thing there's a
very nice way to think about why this
integral would pull out c0 remember we
want to think of this function as a sum
of rotating vectors so consider this
integral this continuous average as
being applied to that whole sum the
average of a sum like this is the same
as the sum over the averages of each
part you can read this move as a sort of
subtle shift in perspective rather than
looking at the sum of all the vectors at
each point in time and taking the
average value that they sweep out look
at the average of an individual vector
as T goes from 0 to 1 and then add up
all these averages but each of these
vectors just makes a whole number of
rotations around 0 so it's average value
as T ranges from 0 to 1 will be 0 the
only exception is the constant term
since it stays static and doesn't rotate
its average value is just whatever
number it happened to start on which is
C 0 so doing this average over the whole
function is a sort of clever way to kill
all of the terms that aren't C 0 but
here's the actual clever part let's say
that you wanted to compute a different
term like C 2 sitting in front of the
vector rotating two cycles per second
the trick is to first multiply f of T
by something that makes that vector hold
still sort of the mathematical
equivalent of giving a smartphone to an
overactive child specifically if you
multiply the whole function by e to the
negative two times two pi I times T
think about what happens to each term
since multiplying Exponential's results
in adding what's in the exponent the
frequency term in each of our exponents
gets shifted down by two so now as we do
our averages of each term that see
negative one vector
spins around negative three times with
an average of zero the C zero vector
previously constant now rotates twice as
T ranges from zero to one so its average
is also zero
and likewise all vectors other than the
C two term make some whole number of
rotations meaning they average out to be
zero so taking the average of this
modified function is a clever way to
kill all of the terms other than c2 and
of course there's nothing special about
the number two here you could replace it
with any other end and you have a
general formula for CN which is what
we're looking for out of context this
expression might look complicated but
remember you can read it as first
modifying our function our 2d drawing so
as to make the nth little vector hold
still and then performing an average
which kills all of the moving vectors
and leaves you only with the still part
isn't that crazy all of the complexity
in these decompositions you're seeing of
drawings into sums of many rotating
vectors is entirely captured in this
little expression so when I'm rendering
these animations that's exactly what I'm
having the computer do it treats the
path like a complex function and for a
certain range of values in it computes
this integral to find the coefficient C
of N
for those of you curious about where the
data for a path itself comes from I'm
going to easy route and just having the
program read in an SVG which is a file
format that defines the image in terms
of mathematical curves rather than with
pixel values so the mapping f of T from
a time parameter two points in space
basically comes predefined in what's
shown right now I'm using 101 rotating
vectors computing the values of n from
negative 50 up to 50 in practice each of
these integrals is computed numerically
basically meaning it chops up the unit
interval into many small pieces of size
delta T and then adds up this value F of
T times e to the negative n to pi I T
times delta T for each one of them there
are fancier methods for more efficient
numerical integration but this gives the
basic idea and after you compute these
101 constants each one determines an
initial angle and magnitude for the
little vectors and then you just set
them all rotating adding them tip to
tail as they go and the path drawn out
by the final tip is some approximation
of the original path you fed in as the
number of vectors used approaches
infinity the approximation path gets
more and more accurate
[Music]
to bring this all back down to earth
consider the example we were looking at
earlier of a step function which
remember was useful for modeling the
heat dissipation between two rods at
different temperatures after they come
into contact like any real number valued
function the step function is like a
boring drawing that's confined to one
dimension but this one is an especially
dull drawing since for inputs between 0
and 0.5 the output just stays static at
the number 1 and then it discontinuously
jumps to negative 1 for inputs between
0.5 and 1 so in the Fourier series
approximation the vector sum stays
really close to 1 for the first half of
the cycle then quickly jumps to negative
1 and stays close to that for the second
half of the cycle and remember each pair
of vectors rotating in opposite
directions corresponds to one of the
cosine waves that we were looking at
earlier to find the coefficients you
would need to compute this integral and
for the ambitious viewers among you
itching to work out some integrals by
hand this is one where you can actually
do the calculus to get an exact answer
rather than just having a computer do it
numerically for you I'll leave it as an
exercise to work this out and to relate
it back to the idea of cosine waves by
pairing off the vectors that rotate in
opposite directions and for the even
more ambitious I'll leave another
exercise up on the screen for how to
relate this more general computation
with what you might see in a textbook
describing Fourier series only in terms
of real valued functions with sines and
cosines by the way if you're looking for
more Fourier series content I highly
recommend the videos by mythology and
the coding train and I'd also recommend
this blog post links of course in the
description so on the one hand this
concludes our discussion of the heat
equation which was a little window into
the study of partial differential
equations but on the other hand this
foray into Fourier series is a first
glimpse at a deeper idea exponential
functions including their generalization
into complex numbers and even matrices
play a very important role for
differential equations especially when
it comes to linear equations what you
just saw breaking down a function is a
combination of these X
initials and using that to solve a
differential equation comes up again and
again in different shapes and forms
[Music]
the
[Music]
you